[Music]
multiplayer online battle arena games or
MOBAs have gained immense popularity in
the last few years with games dota 2 and
League of Legends hitting over 8 million
and 64 million monthly active players
respectively not to mention the millions
of dollars being awarded in the
competitive scene if you're unfamiliar
with the genre members usually play from
a top-down perspective you and a small
team of friends each control a single
character with unique abilities and
attempt to push into the enemy base and
destroyers the large followings of dota
2 and League of Legends have inspired
several triple-a developers to come out
with their own interpretations of the
MOBA formula let's see what some of the
big names have to offer
developed by waystone games and
published by EA dawn gauge says a lot of
gameplay similarities to dota 2 and
League of Legends
however dawn Gate firsts what the
developers call a flexible metal what
does that even mean well in dota 2 and
League of Legends the character you
choose to play pretty much defines your
role in the match a particular
character's abilities might naturally
make them much more suitable to act as a
healing support rather than a damaged
soaking tank for example so the variety
of character combinations that can make
up a team's roster is a huge part of
what is called the meta game but in
Dorne gates players have the option to
pick their role no matter what character
they're playing this is because
selecting different roles affects the
attributes and perks that your character
gets you might earn more currency each
time you kill an enemy player or get a
helpless when you kill neutral creatures
the one gate gives you the tools to play
the same character in vastly different
ways and this flexible meta is its main
draw card
Crytek arena of fate is going for
something punchy R and more accessible
by limiting its matches to 20 minutes
the game still features a large pool of
characters to choose from and the
objective of destroying the enemy teams
base however if the 20 minutes is up and
birth bases still stand
then the team with the most points is
the winner attribute boosting abilities
are unlocked as you level an alternative
to buying attribute boosting items in
shop areas like in dota 2 or League of
Legends making matches faster paced and
getting rid of the need to remember
recipe combination
in Dead Island epidemic items take on a
more persistent role brought to you by
the same people who published at Island
the game calls itself the world's first
zombie mobile or Zomba Dead Island
epidemic features a crafting system that
has players collecting blueprints and
item parts during matches to make and
upgrade their own weapons to use in the
future gameplay revolves around
surviving waves of zombies in addition
to fighting other humans you can also
choose just to fight NPC zombies the
game differentiates itself by letting up
to three different teams of players
battle it out and relies on WASD key
inputs for movement and the mouse to aim
as you can imagine Dead Island epidemic
is a lot more action orientated and
could be mistaken for a top-down shooter
Wizards heroes of the storm draws its
content from the universes of its
existing catalogue of games
this means a roster of characters from
the starcraft Warcraft and Diablo series
like in arena of fate Blizzard is aiming
for matches around 20 minutes long
although this isn't a hard limit the
timeliness is encouraged through the
game's leveling system which has whole
teams leveling up together similar to
arena of fate heroes of the storm has no
items or shops to worry about which gets
rid of the need to consider that extra
information maps specific objectives
regularly popping up encourages the two
teams to confront each other more often
to be completely honest with you it's
hard to imagine MOBA players like myself
breaking away from the games we've
already diverted so much time - but on
the other hand the flexibility themes
and shorter learning curves being
offered by games like dawn Gate arena
fate Dead Island epidemic and heroes of
the storm could bring in a lot of new
players to the genre and give veterans
different things to get excited about do
any of the mentioned games offer
something that interests you or have you
got your heart already set on a
particular game if you've never played a
MOBA game before
what would it have to have to interest
you let us know in the comments below